every one of us has a why it is our
birthright if you will which is you may
not know what it is but every one of us
has one and that is because we are all
the products of our own upbringing
right we are the sum total of the
lessons we learned in the experiences we
had during our during our our youth and
your why is fully formed probably by
your mid to late teens and though you
are who you are and the rest of our
lives simply offer us an opportunity to
make decisions that we may live in
balance with our Y and we know what it
feels like it feels like flow it feels
like I got this what it feels happy it
feels confident it feels joyful where
when you're out of sync with your Y it
feels like stress it feels like ends
anxiety and we can control for that you
know it's just patterns of behavior so
every one of us has our own unique Y and
the opportunity is to combine our
efforts with people whose Y's are
synchronous with ours right we know what
this looks and feels like it looks like
friendship
it looks like successful marriages where
we're not friends with everybody and
there are people who do what we do and
like the things we like but we're not
friends with them because there's a
values thing and there's a worldview
thing and there's a there's all kinds of
things that factor in and so every
partnership is gonna have different
why's the question is why did they start
the firm why did they join this firm
what is the what is the firm's origin
story and what is the firm's just cause
what is the firm's vision right so even
though every single one of us has our
own unique y and every firm has their
own unique Y visions are different a
vision of the future there's only a very
very small percentage of the population
that is visionary right not everybody
has Steve Jobs and Martin Luther King
but and so there's a young generation
puts tremendous pressure on themselves -
what is your vision you don't have to
have one but you do have to find one you
can latch onto someone else's vision and
make it your own and when a firm has a
vision what you want to attract people
who's wise help advance that vision
right or in other words we we come with
common purpose so it's very very very
important for organizations to clearly
express their Just Cause
world that they imagine that does not
yet exist that we will commit our
efforts to help build a vision is not to
be the biggest firm with the highest
quality X the a vision is not to offer
our clients the best possible product
that's not vision that's that we tries
to bed at the beginning that's literally
nothing vision is I have a dream that
one day little black children will hold
hands on the playground with little
white children that's a vision Steve
Jobs had a vision that he imagined a
time in which individuals could stand up
to big brother and one day even an
individual could compete with a major
corporation notice that has nothing to
do with computers the computer was the
perfect tool he saw to advance his
vision so what is the vision what is the
world you imagined that you view your
profession as essential at helping
advance that vision right and when you
start talking about that you start to
attract people who's why then
contributes to the building of that
vision
[Music]